Elon Musk just removed the verification
Badge of the New York Times
Elon Musk tweeted out the real tragedy
of the New York Times is that their
propaganda is not even interesting also
their feed is the Twitter equivalent of
diarrhea it's unreadable they would have
far more real followers if they only
posted their top articles same applies
to all Publications love it absolutely
love it Elon said he was going to start
taking away people's verification badges
on April 1st if they didn't pay Seven
dollars a month I'm not paying seven
dollars a month last I checked I stole
my verification badge I love that Elon
went for the New York Times first they
don't deserve any credibility and any
chance we get to get a billionaire who's
sympathetic to our side who can wield
some power because money talks and Bs
walks I just think that's absolutely
great